the david pakman show at david
pakman.com i've been covering the donald
trump russia relationship or possible
friendship for a long time now and many
people in our audience have resisted it
and over the weekend we have learned so
much about it and we will talk about
that remember last week when Donald
Trump attempted to one-up his earlier
comment suggesting that his supporters
could assassinate Hillary Clinton by
making the assertion that President
Obama founded Isis I'll remind you about
that clip from last week just so we can
all get on the same page
take a look to say Isis is honoring
President Obama right he is the founder
of Isis he's the founder of Isis who's
the founder yeah he and I would say the
co-founder would be crooked Hillary so
repeating it doesn't make it true and as
it turns out Michael McFaul who's a
former US ambassador to Russia and
professor at Stanford University noticed
something interesting about Trump's
Obama founded Isis thing from last week
check out the tweet that former US
ambassador Michael McFaul sent sent
saying by the way
Trump's line that Obama founded Isis
echoes exactly a myth propagated by
Russian state-controlled media and
bloggers and we've talked to you
extensively about these Russian bloggers
and how they spread pro-kremlin and we
also have evidence of pro-trump
propaganda all over the internet and
we've been exploring the connections
between Trump and Russia for a long time
and Trump of course continues to deny
them now let's see let's look at what we
knew prior to this weekend and what we
know now based on a New York Times
article that came out last night if
you're trying to distance yourself
from pro-kremlin pro-putin Russian
factions first of all it might be good
not to parrot their conspiracy theories
on the campaign trail that's number one
we have now learned though that Paul
Manafort Donald Trump's campaign manager
who replaced the fired Corey Lewandowski
is tied to pro-russian politicians in
Ukraine there's a new report from the
New York Times and it exposes some
handwritten ledgers which show that
twelve point seven million dollars in
undisclosed cash payments were
designated for Paul Manafort from mr.
Viktor Yanukovych's pro-russian
political party from 2007 to 2012 this
is according to Ukraine's newly formed
National anti-corruption Bureau and in
addition to that Louis we have now
learned that criminal prosecutors are
investigating offshore shell companies
that helped Viktor Yanukovych's inner
circle finance their lifestyles and
Trump's own campaign manager Paul
Manafort
is now being investigated as of CNN's
statement this morning for possibly
receiving illegal payments in Russia if
you're trying to distance yourself from
Russia Louis maybe parroting pro-russian
talking points and hiring a guy who
reportedly received millions and off the
record payments from pro-russian groups
is not the best way to distance yourself
yeah another example of how Trump seems
to know one who is competent or or
trustworthy or are fantastic or great or
or terrific wants to work for Trump and
the rhetoric when it comes to the
rhetoric I I could easily see the the
the similar rhetoric just being a
coincidence right the Obama rhetoric
that type of thing sure that wouldn't
that wouldn't surprise me but now we're
getting a little deeper and it's it's
kind of ugly and not only that the
rhetoric matching up might be not a big
deal if that was all we had but we also
know that Trump's views on the Ukraine
Russia conflict actually changed after
hiring Paul Manafort Donald Trump first
seemed to support Ukraine
territorial integrity back in September
he spoke by video feed to a gathering of
political and business elites in Kiev
and he said that that his rhetoric was
very very Pro pro-ukrainian and then all
of a sudden Paul Manafort gets involved
and now Trump's rhetoric on Russia is
softening he influences the Republican
National Convention II although he says
he didn't even really know what was
going on which actually further lends
itself to this connection to two Pro
Russia which is that mana for did this
on its own under the guise of being part
of or representative of the Trump
campaign Russia may genuinely see all of
this is hilarious right we've talked
Lewis about how Russia may just think
hey we should try to get Trump elected
because he'll be such an embarrassment
that in contrast Russia will actually
look like a more legitimate player in
the world politics game uh well that
might be it maybe not just looking like
a more legitimate player but perhaps
Putin wants someone in office that he
thinks is weak and that he could easily
manipulate sure and so there could be
very serious consequences not good if
you're trying to show there is no
connection between you and your campaign
and Russia Trump is doing the exact
opposite of what he should be doing at
some point I know the audience will just
stop believing me because our reports
about Trump spokeswoman Katrina Pierson
are getting more and more and more
ridiculous over time but the reports
have all been true and I have yet
another report for you today that may be
hard to believe but it is all too real
after last week President presidential
candidate Donald Trump said that
President Obama founded Isis now Katrina
Pierson went back on CNN and said it's
actually President Obama who invaded
Afghanistan now of course that's not
true
it makes absolutely no sense to just
suggest that it was in 2001 under george
w bush that the United States entered
Afghanistan doesn't matter of course
this is the same Katrina Pierson who
defended a call for a pure-breed
president the same Katrina Pierson who
blamed a soldier's death in 2004 on
President Obama who didn't become
president
until January of 2009 he or she is on
CNN saying hey you know what
President Obama is responsible for the
u.s. invading Afghanistan take a look
pump campaign is back with us now in
Katrina I just want to for factual Seco
sake of just correct information when
you said that Barack Obama took the
country into Afghanistan it was not
during the of course as you know during
the Obama administration when we first
went into Afghanistan
shortly after we're talking about Isis
specifically okay but but your statement
was that Barack Obama took us into
Afghanistan it was his war
it was President Bush who took the
country into Afghanistan shortly after
9/11 but I want to get my sis was Isis
came out of the Obama side of the war oh
is that not a fact no it is not effect
because in 2004 as I stated in the last
segment that AQI al Qaeda in Iraq was
started by Abu Musab al-zarqawi and then
in 2006 it morphed into Iraq the Islamic
state in Iraq and then later became the
Islamic state in Iraq and Syria also
Obama saying that they were the JV team
again the incompetence of even
recognizing the threat while he was in
office and then to make it worse going
into Libya and creating a vacuum leaving
all of those weapons behind essentially
arming the enemy
I hear that argument but that's not the
argument that Donald Trump has been
making he has made over the last several
days that Barack Obama was the founder
of Isis and then said it was sarcastic
he's put his supporters and his
surrogates as we saw this morning in a
really difficult place not knowing when
he's being sincere when he's being so
Katrina nothing you're saying is true I
love how whenever she's called out on
her lies she tries to find some middle
ground like oh hey Katrina when you said
Obama took us to war in Afghanistan you
were completely factually wrong okay but
Victor can't we agree that at least
Obama is the Antichrist and responsible
for the death of John F Kennedy
no Katrina we also can't say that and
this is a
known technique Louis to try to find the
middle ground to sort of try to
establish some agreement from which then
you can have smaller differences but she
just fails miserably every single time
she really I we we think she should be
fired because she seems to be completely
incompetent but yeah who would take her
place is the real question Healy
Baumgartner even Gardner I know it's
scary and and yeah it's it's just
non-stop Obama bashing I'm not sure what
that achieves she just spews nonsense
like Trump all the time and although I
will say this
at least she admits even if it's just a
one-word admission she will admit when
she said something completely false
she said no in other words agreeing that
no it was not true what she said but a
whole bunch of other reasons why you
should still accept basically everything
she says without any kind of scrutiny
whatsoever anything else would be
liberal media bias
I've actually been hearing from people
as Trump likes to say people are telling
me that President Obama actually
assassinated Franz Ferdinand and set in
motion the events that led to World War
one now I'm not saying that but people
have been telling me that Louis and
maybe we need to stop for a second and
figure out what the hell is going on
there's only so far you can go in retro
actively blaming Obama for things that
happened when he wasn't even a senator I
feel like the late 90s of the limit for
what you can blame Obama for now of
course he was basically a kid at the
time but but that that's about as far
back as you can go world war one world
war two that's a little too far it is a
little too far but Miss Pearson and and
Trump might say you haven't taken it far
enough so maybe even the Civil War we
can blame Obama for hey this is sort of
strange Donald Trump spoke at Sacred
Heart University in Connecticut over the
weekend and he said to the audience hey
I might actually lie to you he turned to
the audience and pointed to a high
school kid that he introduced who's
fighting cancer and said that he
wouldn't lie to the kid whose name is
Giacomo Brancato he said I wouldn't lie
to the kid who's fighting cancer but to
all you people
I might actually lie this was a very
strange speech
went on for about an hour it was long it
was rambling it had no direction no
common sense just a very very strange
strange speech and Trump sort of capping
it the cherry on top of the speech is
telling the crowd
I might just lie to all you people
everybody but this one kid next to me I
might be lying too it was very weird and
I'll play it for you
this is 100% certain okay I'm telling
this DiGiacomo
right I might lie to you like Hillary
doesn't all the time but I'll never lie
to Giacomo okay yeah all right John come
on you helped me to it
we're gonna build the wall but
whoo-hoo-hoo he's gonna pay for the wall
the funniest thing is that immediately
after saying he wouldn't lie to Giacomo
but he would lie to the audience maybe
he told a lie which is that Mexico is
gonna pay for that wall there's no
chance in hell Louis that Mexico is
paying for that wall which will likely
not even be built but there he
immediately lied to the audience I guess
it's good that he's finally being honest
and saying I might lie to you here's lie
number one immediately after it's it's
good yes he's admitting that he's a liar
but in Donald Trump's defense Dave yeah
we're gonna that the devil is in the
details here he he never said Mexico was
gonna pay for a wall all he said was who
is going to pay for the wall and the
audience said it was Mexico right he
told the lie but then he said 100 lines
of Giacomo when he said we're gonna
build the wall cuz he knows it's not
gonna happen
everything about this campaign is nuts
this particular rally Trump showed up a
half-hour late no air conditioning in
the building remember how hot it was
this weekend in the Northeast a bunch of
people had to be treated for heat
related symptoms Trump rambles aimlessly
for more than an hour before telling the
crowd that he might lie to them if there
were to be a documentary made about the
Trump campaign I might be lying to you
would be a really good title I could see
like an independent Netflix style
documentary called I might be lying to
you and it's all about the Trump
campaign yeah I might be lying to you or
or this I will tell you maybe just
terrific remember the good old days when
MIT Romney seemed like sort of a
run-of-the-mill out-of-step so
conservative I would love to go back to
those days before before the Republican
nominee was truly evidence that a
significant portion of this country has
descended into total insanity Mitt
Romney was just a normal guy and he
looks great right now yeah he was just
you're you like you said run-of-the-mill
Republican nothing the major donors big
corporations or
Joe the Plumber type guys had to worry
about you know what is actually great
about Trump going up on stage and saying
I might lie to you PolitiFact a value
evaluated that statement and they've
determined it's 100% true this is the
first time PolitiFact has ever said
something Trump said is actually true
usually it's like partially untrue pants
on fire total lie Trump's saying to the
audience he might lie to them finally is
actually a true statement according to
PolitiFact
great work done by PolitiFact i don't
think i needed them to know that that
was accurate but thank you
what's Trump even doing in Connecticut
anyway I mean there's a poll where Trump
is only like five or six points behind
Hillary in Connecticut let's take that I
was in Connecticut that's with seventeen
percent of respondents saying they don't
yet know who they're going to vote for
it seems like a total waste of time for
Trump or you can't completely forsake
any state regardless of what the numbers
look like there if that's that's good
campaigning really I'd love to see Trump
here in Massachusetts great use of time
that would be that would be an
interesting when it actually would be
great because we could show up an
interview from supporters send me your
thoughts on this I'm on twitter at des
Pakman and we have such a great show for
you today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is even little steven thank you so much
for being a david pakman show member of
course this is viewer and listener
supported independent media and i
encourage you to check out the brand new
david pakman show website at david
pakman.com and also although i don't
have any more of the membership specials
i talked about last week there is still
a discount code that is only on my
Instagram feed last week I posted a
screenshot of the new website and that
post contains a coupon code you can use
to get a great membership discount I'm
David Pakman on Instagram still some of
those available I'll also remind you we
are taking your calls this week
Wednesday Wednesday 1:15 p.m. Eastern
Time that will be Wednesday August 15th
no that's today Wednesday August 17th I
always get the date wrong Louis for when
we're taking calls but we are taking
them on Wednesday 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and
that'll be a great time
that's fantastic every time we take
calls it's wonderful and please feel
free to ask us about something other
than the election oh yeah we take
questions on any topic 1:15 p.m. Eastern
on Wednesday ok there were some
interesting items purchased through our
amazon link over the last week of course
if you ever shop on Amazon what I
suggest is first stop by david
pakman.com slash amazon and then
everything you buy will send us a little
kickback a mr. robot episodes being
streamed by many in our audience i'm
completely up to speed on this show and
louis every time i recommend mr. robot
to someone they say what what channel is
that on and I say oh it's on USA and
immediately people start trash-talking
saying USA has no good shows and then as
soon as they watch the show they come
back to me apologetic saying David I'm
sorry I'm really sorry that I critiqued
you for recommending a USA show because
the show is fantastic yes I still have
yet to see it
be honest but I'm getting there I just
have so much on my plate right now when
it comes to to television and Jason
you've watched some episodes of mr.
robot although after I recommended it to
Jason he started on season two which is
I would start at season one personally
but your are you enjoying it so far
yeah thoroughly enjoy it my favorite
part was they did an episode where they
kind of didn't homage to older episodes
and then yeah kind of like an 80s bit
with you know anyways without giving
anything away what Jason what Jason is
referring to is there's an episode that
looks like an 80s sitcom essentially
with the laugh track and it has a
purpose in the story which you would
figure out if you watch it I thought
that that was very very well I mean
everything down to the music was like
you were watching an eighties show yeah
alright well that maybe people had more
to add over there Battlestar Galactica
also some people in our audience
streaming both the new and old
Battlestar Galactica series as you know
Lois the new Battlestar Galactica one of
my favorite shows I've never seen the
original one I started watching the
original because it was on Netflix or I
don't know if it still is it was at some
point I started watching and I just
couldn't do it it was it just wasn't
doing it for me really it well it's it's
fit quite old then it I you maybe it
just doesn't hold up you're finding it
dated in other words yeah I'm not really
into the original Star Trek series
either for some of the same reasons um
but hey I'm entitled to my opinion so
please nobody shoot me over this Jason
any comments on Battlestar or Star Trek
you want to make I can't say I've even
seen Battlestar Galactica
but I know all to say is going to you
number two okay I you're number two
let's continue david pakman.com slash
amazon is the place to stop in before
you do your shopping on Amazon okay I
have some really disturbing news to
report to you about the Constitution
which social and constitutional
conservatives claim to really value
Donald Trump said late last week that he
would support trying US citizens
suspected of terror
in military tribunals this is yet
another one of Donald Trump's
harebrained suggestions that is at worst
unconstitutional and at best would be
tied up for years in court if Donald
Trump actually tried to do this Trump
said to the Miami Herald that he doesn't
at all like the idea of trying terrorist
suspects in the civilian court system
and he added that he would be quote fine
with trying US citizens in military
tribunals for example at Guantanamo Bay
in Cuba now the only problem with this
Luis is that there is this thing called
due process which US citizens are
entitled to due process generally
defined as quote fair treatment through
the normal judicial system especially as
a citizens entitlement military
tribunals Lewis not exactly the normal
judicial system are they not quite this
is to me this is just typical Trump
pandering and it's pretty easy to pander
to conservatives all one of the top
three things you can do is just talk
about the military and now we're talking
about the military and and treason and
terrorism and and tribunals I'm sure
they're eating it all up this actually
came up here in Boston after the Boston
Marathon bombing yes suggested by some
that so hard tsarnaev be tried in a
military tribunal and of course many
more level-headed Republicans like John
McCain for example as well as anyone who
has even a passing understanding of the
Constitution were opposed to that Trump
I don't you you presented the
possibility Louis that Trump is
pandering I actually want to suggest
that he just has no idea what he's
talking about that this is more
ignorance than anything else because
whenever Trump says one of these things
and is asked a follow-up question about
it immediately it's clear there's
nothing there right the the wheel is
spinning but the hamster has been dead
for a while is maybe one way we can sort
of think about what's going on there I
think the guy just doesn't have the
slightest idea what he's talking about
military tribunals military yeah I mean
I don't know sure it sounds kind of good
I agree and I'm picturing his response
now to a follow-up question on military
Tribunal's he would just talk about how
how much we are in danger because of
terrorists yeah
but I would say that the - but just
being clueless and pandering are not
mutually exclusive no and there's a big
overlap if we imagine the Venn diagram
of both pandering and being clueless
there's actually pretty significant
overlap there yeah so it's both for sure
but I don't really know how effective
this is this method of pandering but but
talking about the military talking about
how strong he wants to make the military
a lot of his fans love it
I like when Trump says something
completely off the wall like this that
would make you question even his mental
stability and then Republicans like Paul
Ryan will respond by saying something
like I'm opposed to suggestions by
Donald Trump that his opponent be killed
if she wins but I do support the
Republican Party and we'll be voting for
Trump in November right Trump suggests
ignoring the Constitution and putting US
citizens suspected of terror into
military tribunals I support the
Constitution and the rights afforded to
all by it and Donald Trump's comments
are not representative of the Republican
Party but I will be supporting Donald
Trump in November as he is the best
option for our country every time one of
these comments is made there's some
slightly reasonable Republicans who say
these are dangerous comments that I
disavow but we've got to keep Hillary
out of the White House and I will be
supporting Donald Trump in November
there's a lot of those people there's a
lot of that sentiment and unfortunately
we're stuck in this two-party system and
can you imagine if Hillary Clinton
suggested ignoring the US Constitution
in this way the entire right-wing
apparatus including establishment
Republicans and right-wing media would
say that that statement alone
disqualifies Hillary at large right big
picture from being President of the
United States Trump says it offhandedly
sure let's just put citizens into
military tribunals barely a blip on the
right-wing media radar yeah
Hillary would there might be riots if
Hillary said that legitimately we've
been hoping suggesting letting you know
that the DEA this summer was going to
decide whether
marijuana's would be kept as a Schedule
one drug or rescheduled and this is
really important because schedule one
drugs by their very classification are
much more difficult to research for
medical uses they're generally criminai
xin a much more aggressive way and the
definition of schedule one drugs is that
there is no currently accepted medical
use and a high potential for abuse the
DEA
thought about it as we said they were
and they decided to keep marijuana as a
schedule 1 drug based on quote
scientific and medical evaluation that
they did in partnership with the Food
and Drug Administration here is a quote
from the DEA about this decision saying
the DEA and the FDA continue to believe
that scientifically valid and well
controlled clinical trials conducted
under investigational new drug
applications are the most appropriate
way to conduct research on the medicinal
uses of marijuana yeah
it's the most appropriate way Louis if
you're trying to keep that research very
limited very difficult very expensive
and progressing incredibly slowly yes
this this really has nothing to do with
the research maybe a little bit to do
with the research because as it relates
to funding but to me this is all about
just maintaining the structure and size
of the DEA because let's face it most of
what they do revolves around pot does it
not there's a lot of self-interest
because marijuana enforcement brings in
a ton of money not just for the DEA but
for a ton of agencies and local police
agencies in many cases as well let me
show you the list of schedule 1 drugs
that are on that same list as marijuana
and again schedule 1 drugs defined as
drugs with no currently accepted medical
use in a high potential for abuse so the
list includes heroin LSD marijuana
ecstasy peyote and quaaludes this
reminds me of that little kid game Louis
which one is not like the others and you
might be interested to know that the
painkiller vicodin as well as meth and
oxy code
our schedule to drugs this is not a
scheduling of marijuana that makes much
sense is it on a side note we also know
that ecstasy actually does have medical
uses yeah yeah right right a good point
apart from that this is yes this is all
about this is just the the higher-ups at
the DEA and other federal agencies being
greedy
yeah it's about money it's about keeping
people's jobs it's about maintaining the
status quo which is good to them with no
concern for the citizens of this country
and it's also demonstrably false that
there's no medical use right we know of
cannabis oil extract being very helpful
in controlling the symptoms of epilepsy
and seizures we know that it's been
useful in treating nausea as a side
effect for a variety of medications
including chemotherapy and there's this
sort of catch-22 where in order to do
more research scientists need to do more
studies in order to do that the studies
have to be approved by federal agencies
including the DEA and the FDA and
occasionally the National Institute on
Drug Abuse but it's much more difficult
to get those approvals while it is
schedule one where are you on this issue
Jason I know it seemed earlier like you
have very strong feelings about this
research issue
well actually did some interviews that's
of some researchers at UCSF one point
and you know they're actually you know
not about marijuana but about LSD and
they're actually using it for
Alzheimer's patients and I hope them
kind of cope with their end of death
syndrome as well as I know there's uses
for certain native tribes with the use
peyote to kind of you know to solve kind
of the same thing major anxiety issues
and yes you know there's there are
definite uses for you know not only
marijuana but LSD peyote to you know to
solve major issues with the brain
there's no logically consistent case to
me and I think Jason is is getting at
this correctly for legal cigarettes
legal alcohol and not marijuana period
whatever your personal feelings are
about smoking weed right and as you know
Louis I believe that the actual smoking
process of anything is demonstrably bad
for your lungs that's a separate issue
like my personal views about
stuff are completely different from the
empirical sort of bankruptcy of saying
Oh cigarettes should be legal and
alcohol should be legal but it should be
difficult to even study medicinal uses
of marijuana well and you don't need to
smoke it but let's add another huge one
opiates are legal too and these harmful
incredibly addictive painkillers are is
that's what we give to people who are
suffering from pain when they could be
using marijuana products which is it's
far safer and and far less addictive
arguably not addictive at all instead
we're loading them up on on percocets
and vicodins and oxys and not to mention
when you look at the schedule to nature
of a lot of those opiate painkillers
that lewis mentions in the northeast
where there's a real problem with the
heroin epidemic if you look at how many
heroin addicts started with a legitimate
prescription for opiate painkillers
because of an injury they had or for
whatever reason it's huge so those
schedule 2 drugs that are apparently not
as as concerning as marijuana based on
the scheduling are in many cases
actually a gateway to heroin use and we
still have really no strong evidence
that opening up cannabis for medical
research will actually serve as a
gateway to other drug use the entire
system is bankrupt lewis this decision
by the fda we had sort of our hopes up
that there would be a rescheduling but
ultimately the status quo prevailed yeah
like it tends to do the DEA just
completely morally bankrupt at this
point hey make sure to check out our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it as our ez e di
tea you can suggest stories there and so
much more
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
welcome back to the David Pakman show
we have a big announcement to make on
the show the David Pakman show as you
know it is going to be ending in a few
weeks in the sense that producer Louis
is going to be departing from the
program now Louis this may come as a
shock to many in the audience we didn't
have an interview today specifically
because partially we want to discuss
this with you because I think it will be
both shocking debilitating and exciting
to different people in the audience of
course many people don't want you to be
part of the show many people don't want
me to even be part of the show it's
crazy people want the David Pakman show
most will just don't want the show to
exist at all right yeah no that's fair
so let's explore this louis give us the
backstory and I will allow you to
present why you will be leaving the
great city of Boston and maybe that
classification is great is something
that is related to this story yes I
might not classify it that way but city
life is just is just not for me I have
determined and while I I enjoy doing the
show it's uh it is not for show related
reasons that I'm leaving the show I just
really don't want to be anywhere near
the city it's it's it sounds like people
aren't gonna believe me when I say that
but it's really that simple talk a
little bit about because you affair
we've talked about sort of the two big
things that you're looking for in your
next place and the city part is one of
them and there's another and this might
be interesting insight into Louis's
psyche yeah okay well I mean I I don't
want to live in in complete isolation
and be a hermit and be three hours from
the nearest restaurant okay so I would
like to be close to a a population
center but not one the size of Boston
and you compared to
so many of the population centers as
they're called in his country Boston's
pretty small sure but still too big for
me and and so I would like to be
somewhere a bit more rural but still
close to at least a medium-sized city
and what do you consider medium because
it's so it's all perspective like coming
from New York City for me Boston is
small right feels very small it's four
miles across or whatever I you know very
very small so for your perspective what
would be like a suitable size metro area
to be near but not in yeah I would say
between a hundred and fifty thousand and
three hundred and fifty thousand people
would be suitable okay but not to live
in to live near to live near right right
and so I I don't want to deal with the
the noise the smells the traffic the the
cement and concrete everywhere and all
of that stuff and I also really don't
want to deal with winter ah so now we're
getting into part two yes part two is I
I really I really do not like winter I
am not designed to tolerate winter well
is this because of your Persian and
Jewish ethnicity no probably mostly
because I'm I'm really Finn okay and
whatever that means I mean as it relates
to winter and and dealing with it
so there's all of that and just the the
city life just not feeling it need a
little bit more room a little more green
a little more space and a little more
peace and quiet so big picture you would
be looking to be outside of an area
outside of a city that's no more than
300 thousand people in a part of the
country where and are you saying where
there is no winter or what would be like
the low winter temperature that you
would tolerate
I mean mild very mild winters would be
fine right and so I'm thinking that I
wouldn't be dealing with snow fall and
that temperatures wouldn't really be
dropping below freezing so 32 at the
coldest day is sort of your baseline and
even that I don't
really like but yeah that would be I
suppose that would be acceptable if I'm
not dealing with the precipitation and
all of that right for many people and I
think this will be sort of an eye-opener
when we've explained to a few people off
air what's going on they say I'm
genuinely interested in this louis
because a lot of people would decide
where to live based on things like
proximity to family how many people you
know there and sort of whether there's a
specific job or occupation that you
would be participating in but you've
sort of decided that the really
important things are climate and sort of
level of urbanity for lack of a better
term well it's I know why people choose
to live why those decisions are
important to people why they decide to
live in a certain place like you
mentioned close to family employment
opportunities so on and so forth yeah
but that is not really like when I moved
to Boston I kind of convinced myself
that I'd liked it and I thought to
myself yes well my family's here and
well my friends are here and and this
job it's great I love it
but none of that ended up battery
knitting and so and maybe not everyone
is the same as me but first I would like
to find a place where I know I can enjoy
living right and then the friends the
the work all of that stuff that will
happen do you have any concern and I ask
this not rhetorically and not implying
anything I say it with peace and love do
you have any concern that sometimes the
grass can seem greener on the other side
the grass is the grass is greener in
other places yes I I lived in Austin for
two years and as many people know and
and this the the city stuff was really
getting to me there but despite that I
left about ten miles north of downtown
it was uh I mean I would take that over
Boston any day and to be perfectly
honest I would take that over Western
Mass where I'm from any day
despite the city stuff that I
have to deal with in a place like Austin
so we have a number of different special
Louis tributes planned we have something
that our segment producer and interred
intern John astutely called bistro
linguistics which is going to be airing
in over the next few weeks as Louis
transitions out and it is basically a
compilation of Louis's greatest
food-related moments and you know he's
had many of them on the show and we also
have John working on a really great
Louis highlight video he's literally
working on it as we speak
I think I can't see his screen but I'm
sort of counting on the fact that he is
working on that if you have any favorite
Louis moments that you would like
included in this video by all means let
me know and then I will make sure that
that gets to John and we will continue
to celebrate Louis's involvement in and
contributions to the David Pakman show
overtime and that there will be a lot of
compelling and and funny and interesting
moments for people and of course the if
I accidentally had a kid I'd probably
love the kid moment that is a must on
any compilation video yes we were
considering putting that in the bistro
linguistics video even though I had
nothing to do with it just because of
how fond David is of it yeah so we have
as you know we have Rachel who's been
participating on the show one day a week
she's going to be adding a second day
starting very very soon we also have
producer Jason Shepard who has been
under the tutelage of Lewis as I like to
say are you taking it all in Jason I
mean this is you've been thrown into
essentially a well I don't know I don't
know what you've been thrown into
awesome into a into a chasm yeah but how
do you feel about Lewis's
prioritizations and decision and and how
does it all feel because you recently
moved back to the Boston area yeah so I
feel like we're we're almost just like
switching roles lives here where I was
on the west coast for the last kind of
eight years and I would almost recommend
recommend where I was this place called
Santa Barbara California seems like it
was almost made for you never never
warmer than 70 never colder than you
know 65 yeah maybe snow one day every
other year on the mountains
so I'll throw those that there but I
feel I have some big shoes to fill
trying to pick up everything that he is
putting down if you will and I feel like
I'm you know slowly getting it all but
yeah Louis I think if I can speak for
you and I don't mean to Santa Barbara
would be great except I think it would
be even too urban and you hate
California don't you oh I don't I don't
hate California I I don't like LA that's
what California is also very expensive
and oh so that's kind of a third thing
right you're looking for a place maybe
where a cost of living is lower than on
the coasts so to speak on the on the
North East Coast and the west coast that
would be nice yes because well right now
it's just ridiculous here in Boston and
it's it's getting a lot worse and I
would like to avoid that I'm sure at
Boston of course probably more expensive
in Santa Barbara but but California
overall is very expensive all right so
that is the big announcement we will be
taking everybody's feedback over the
next several weeks Luis will continue to
be here with us and we will continue
talking about it and I know Luis that
there will be some people who will email
and will be absolutely devastated by
this decision and of course we can
understand that there will be people who
will be absolutely thrilled by this
decision and of course we can expect
that and many people don't like you many
people don't like me yet they do watch
the show with regularity
and there will be many people who will
assume that this means I am the next
person to transition out of the David
Pakman show which of course it doesn't
really make sense but I know that now
that the window has been open some
people will hope that I will soon be
gone from my own show and that's to be
expected right it is yes I'm very
curious to see what the responses will
be and yeah well just yeah have at it
yeah hit me luck I am and with peace and
love we bring you this announcement
we will take a break and a lot more to
talk about that the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I received an email from Alan which I'm
going to show you and it's related to
the Olympics he said David I'd like to
know why there have been no reports in
the mainstream media or even on online
news sources such as TYT Tom Hartman
secular talk or yourself concerning the
incidents of anti-semitic / anti Israeli
behavior at the Olympics such as the
Lebanese team trainer refusing to allow
the Israeli team on the bus or the
Egyptian judoka refusing to shake his
Israeli opponents hand after the match
the world seems to watch everything
Israel does with a microscope but turns
a blind eye
whenever the slights are against Israel
well listen I can't speak for the other
shows right I've had these stories
bookmarked and just haven't gotten to
them but let's look at it and you're
absolutely right Alan that there is an
obsession with Israel for many for some
it's rooted in anti-semitism for others
it's rooting and pushing what they
believe to be progressive ideas or
something but as I've said before anti
Israeli bias goes way beyond what makes
sense over policy disagreements as well
as anti-semitism and we know that
anti-semitism is way more acceptable
than many other types of discrimination
today in 2016 the 2016 Summer Olympics
have been happening in Brazil there's
been a number of really horrible
incidents one is that Lebanese Olympians
refused to travel on the same bus as the
Israeli Olympians and some were even
trying to block the Israeli athletes
from getting on the bus as Israeli
players tried to get on the bus the head
of the Lebanese Olympic delegation tried
to block the aisle and the entrance and
eventually to avoid an incident another
bus was sent for the Lebanese players
and the Israeli players ultimately got
on the bus that they were assigned to if
your reaction when I tell you this is
that hey people are standing up when
they see injustice in Israel's policy
and that's what these actions were with
regard to the bus think about it for a
second if US Olympians try to get on a
bus with Italian Olympians and the
Italians didn't want the US Olympians on
the bus because their a way their their
way against the drone policy of the
United States
would people be supporting that or would
they say hey these are American athletes
they don't have anything to do with
drones you're being fools but somehow
with Israel Louis it doesn't make the
headlines in the same way there's a
different standard applied yeah those
who are obsessed with the BDS movement
don't seem to be concerned with any
other country in the world that might be
perpetrating some type of human rights
violation if you ask them they say they
are concerned with that but they're not
of course they're not they they dedicate
what why do we never hear them talk
about people who were displaced and and
and and out of their ancestral homes in
China or what's going on in North Korea
or what's going on in Sudan or slave
labor in Qatar or you name it
the list goes on and on these people are
not trying to to fight any of that they
are not speaking out about any of that
it's only Israel another example is that
on his way to the finals in the men's
hundred kilogram plus judo weight class
Israeli judoka or SAS on defeated an
Egyptian named Aslam L a hobby and after
Hassan or Sasson defeated L Shahab II
and attempted to shake hands you know
sportsmanship L Shahab II refused and
here is a picture of that going on
imagine Michael Phelps and a swimmer
from Spain on the medal podium and after
the anthem is played Michael Phelps goes
to shake hands with the Spanish swimmer
and the swimmer refuses because he
doesn't like American foreign policy who
would support that and L Shahab II was
reportedly under pressure from Islamic
groups and Egyptian nationalists not to
even fight or Sasson to just back out
altogether I guess we should be glad he
didn't at least do that and then the
stories continue there was an Olympic
qualifying match and Allah gas hoon who
is a boxer from Syria just flat-out
refused to fight an Israeli athlete and
gesund said that competing with an
Israeli athlete would mean that he
recognizes the State of Israel so like I
said many times this isn't just about
justice for Palestinians in the West
Bank and Gaza very clearly for some it
is that they don't even want to read
cognized that Israel is a country this
is a completely laughable position in
2016
another judo fighter reportedly
forfeited a match also so is not to face
an Israeli athlete
unfortunately these stories haven't
actually made much news there is one
story related to Israel and the Olympics
that I've seen among the so-called left
and it's a story about how Palestinian
swimmer Marie al-atrash
supposedly had no way of training in an
Olympic sized pool because as the story
goes there are none in the Palestinian
territories and she just can't get a
pool to practice in imagine the the
confusion when I looked into this and it
turns out that the story is not even
true Israeli officials made it clear
that first of all Marielle at rosh never
even requested a permit to train in
jerusalem which would have been granted
and she would have been able to train in
jerusalem and it's also been pointed out
that there are several Olympic size
pools in the Palestinian territories and
it is so disappointing louis when the
insane anti Israeli bias that some call
anti-semitism in these particular cases
is basically ignored but a non-story
crafted merely for PR value that is
demonstrably false is the one story that
makes it into media more broadly
speaking it's already disappointing
Bester said this is a microcosm of the
whole thing because everyone who is so
you know crazy with this BDS stuff into
Israel stuff they are victims of what
might be the world's one of the world's
best propaganda movements and propaganda
machines not to say that Israel has done
nothing wrong believe me they have
there's plenty of stuff we can point out
of course but but still there is this
gigantic propaganda machine around the
whole Israel Palestine conflict and and
that's why none of these people care
about anything else that's happening in
the world
they are only focused on Israel big news
from the world of making a murderer
Brendan Dassey was convicted in 2007 in
the murder of
referre Teresa Halbach this was a huge
Netflix documentary series called making
a murderer brendan dassey's uncle Steven
Avery also convicted of that murder I
have been saying for months since I
first commented on this that Brendan
Dassey whatever his involvement was or
was not in that murder he was not of the
mental capacity to even understand what
was going on he gave a completely
coached confession to investigators who
questioned him without his mother
present and the big news is that the
conviction of Brendan Dassey has been
overturned by a federal judge in
Milwaukee according to court documents
that have been obtained by a number of
news outlets there are now 90 days
during which this decision can be
appealed and otherwise Brendan will go
free I believe this is the right
decision louis i happen to have real
questions about whether Brendan Dassey
was involved at all I'm not sure if
Steven Avery was actually involved but
as far as brendan dassey's involvement
doesn't matter this is a kid of low IQ
demonstrably low confirmed by the court
and the judge's ruling says that who had
no clue what on earth was going on and
if you watch the documentary you would
see investigators saying Brendan tell us
what you did to Teresa and he says oh we
we stabbed her and that wasn't the right
answer to investigator so they go
Brendan tell us what you really did stop
lying now tell us the truth about what
you did we shot her that's right Brendan
that's what you did a total fishing
expedition a total violation of what
should have been this kid's actual
rights with regard to this prosecution
and I believe that this is the right
decision yeah it's well that was maybe
one of the hardest things I ever had to
watch yeah was and the whole series is
great if it wasn't for this series this
would not have happened and we are gonna
continue following it as far as Steven
Avery as well which is a whole other
story yeah well I hear that there's
going to be a new season it's so this of
course has been continuing and I believe
that he is innocent as well I could be
wrong just my opinion
so I cheers to the documentary to the
filmmakers and I'm happy for Brendan if
you believe that Brendan Dassey that
there were no problems at all with the
prosecution of Brendan Dassey and that
he should be sitting in prison send me
an email because I truly don't get it we
have a voicemail number it's two one
nine two david p here's a real quick
voicemail that you may find interesting
take a listen
yes David mister pac-man you gorgeous
little rascal you such what are you
married I thought I heard you say she
had children a boy a little girl but
that's something you deserve because you
are good man this is old crazy
hypocritical Hicks Lonzo Hicks from
Mosier shreveport-bossier Louisiana
Banana Republic of the south
alright let's cut it there yeah I I'm
not married I've never said that I have
kids and that's that glad to get an
opportunity to clear that up and Bossier
City sounds like an interesting place I
would be very interested in seeing what
exactly goes on down there we've got a
great bonus show today I don't even have
time to tell
and you can sign up and get access to it
at david pakman.com slash
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you